see the world's most powerful
superheroes in the world's most
immersive film experience
don't miss Dark Phoenix in IMAX in June
get your tickets today
what is this
place
welcome to the school for the gifted
we are now seeing the beginnings of another
stage of human evolution
the truth is mutants are very real
and they are among us
here you have the chance to be part of
something much bigger than yourself
forget everything you think you know
you're not kids anymore
you're x-men
the wars still coming
Charles and I intend to fight it
you want to shoot me, shoot me!
you ready for this
a new tomorrow starts today
the world is on the brink
she's changing
into what?
when I lose control, bad things happen
but it feels good
tell me how we fix this Charles cuz don't know what to do
are you threatening me
that's right
that would be a bad idea
they're right to fear me